he knocked out this guy in an MMA fight
and then he W and my buddy Kenny is
Chinese he's Taiwanese he walked around
the cage
[Laughter]
[Music]
like all right Nick let us
know if this is really supposed to be a
disqualification oh oh dude okay now
you're in the most insane Jiu-Jitsu
match and DQ these make me sad kind of
oh you can't do that I didn't know you
couldn't do that I've been slapped a lot
and no one's disqualified the other
guy oh he headbutted them up was that
okay was that anything wrong with that
no well it's just like there's a lot of
things that are like on the line but
that's considered like dirty that might
be something that that dive that like
cuz he kind of head butt he L with his
oh okay
Sedum stop me stop me whenever something
is like that you can't do that got
it I think he slaps him right here know
so he's already mad he's
like I think he gave him points already
huh was he mad about the head
butt kind of kicked him a little bit see
it's like it's like little things it's
like okay you're escalating the
situation you can't kick like that he
kicked his chest well he like he's he's
moving in ways where you're like ah
you're trying to be trying to be a funny
guy he's trying to he's trying to bend
be a funny guy what's with the
G what was that nothing he he tried to
attempt a pass so he headbutt him he's
using his head a lot right yeah which is
not really necessar what's what's this
he was trying to get to his back and he
he went for a cow cowgirl position
situation cowgirl position that's what
it's called a Jitsu you wouldn't
understand anything I wouldn't
understand because uh that's a different
reference than I'm referencing thing sex
yeah dude all you see is sex huh I
see that little foot thing like he's
escalating the situation again did he
slap him in the head though first that
looked like he slapped him in the head
like did he put can he go back a little
bit I think I missed in the head right
there you keep on saying escalating the
situation what's the situation well you
know you're you're grappling B guys
hands oh yeah pushes him and he kicks
him he slapped in the head yeah you
can't do that slap in the head well it's
on the ref to be like hey relax dude is
the ref making these calls no the ref's
horrible really that's a bad ref but
then again sometimes it's like these
guys are there for a weekend they don't
usually ref they're not really watching
things so far is the bald guy the main
violator in all this yeah he's being
he's being dirty guy oh he got him in a
triangle what happened right there so he
put him in a triangle he put him in a
submission and it's it's looking pretty
tight what are what are the calls being
made is that coach she's saying stop oh
she's
saying someone saying a yellow
card to
who no idea see this is the other thing
too is like sometimes if you don't have
a good ref is that the ref the girl
she's a ref and they had another Chief
ref talking to her about something so
she's in her ear about like hey oh
there's another ref talking to that ref
she she was talking her
earlier is that usually how it is
there's a ref and then there's a ref for
sometimes yeah what the hell but this
seems like a smaller
tournament PE yeah there's all this
rumbling I don't know what they're even
talking
about so far are you a fan of the bald
guy no no one likes the bald guy this is
a weird match already is a weird match
it's
like that's it that's
it getting that pass anyway go
see he
not he's sting to his butt he's trying
to play his
guard so here's another thing too
whenever there's other coaches and
they're yelling people from the crowd
like it seems like the I don't know if
the ref is talking to other Chief refs
on the other side of the camera but
there she's talking to maybe other
coaches like cuz there's some Rumblings
going on cuz sometimes coaches will be
like what the [__] ref what are you
doing uh and then she looks like I don't
know if she's talking to refs or maybe
other like other uh coaches so she's not
also facilitating it correctly yeah well
just it's just like just just is a
cluster [__] yeah you got to like you
got to contain people and be like hey
what you're doing is not okay like just
[__] stop so that ref is not
maintaining good I think so yeah I think
a good ref will maintain it here's where
it gets to that really obvious
part so he he reached
here so he reached for his head for like
a to Grapple yeah a collar tie that's
what they call it but he's like grabbing
it really hard so he slapped him and
that was like the third fourth time he
already did it so the [__] was
like I'm going slap you right back and
then the ref goes all right that's it
but you'll see stuff like that happen
Jitsu matches where it'll slowly and
that's why I keep saying like it'll
escalate it'll escalate if you don't if
you don't if you're not aware of that
then it's like certain things that are
seen as dirty in Jiu-Jitsu it's like in
basketball like I'll set a there's times
where I set a SC
and then you know how people would nor
run into the screen and it's a
successful one right well what people
would do to me when I set a screen is
they get their elbow and they'll go like
this right into my chest so when they
run into me it's just all elbow to chest
and then I'm just like oh shoot and then
the screen they just run and that means
you get them back next time and that's
how you escalate the situation then you
stick your foot out a little bit damn so
that would be um that's a complete DQ
for to slap somebody yeah for sure for
sure for sure but but the other guy was
exactly right so it everyone's line
depending on the ji Jitsu Federation
that you're competing at everyone's line
is so different like one of our buddies
he was in a Jitsu uh he was in a Jitsu
tournament his name is coach Kenny at
the gym he's a sweetheart we love him to
death but he's like a really funny dude
and he was winning his match he beat
this guy by one point and uh after they
had a camera guy coming around filming
and he filmed and he went up to my boy
Kenny and he was like taking pictures
and filming and then Kenny like double
he just he's a wild boy and he just
double burds the camera and the ref and
this is after the match the match is
already over the the the the ref goes
like he starts talking to somebody else
and then they take two points away for
unsportsmanlike conduct right and then
he loses
the that's a thing and I didn't know
that right he didn't really know that he
just was like just being funny cuz after
the match yeah it's over and MMA he does
that and this is the guy that I told
stories about he knocked out this guy in
MMA fight and then he W and my buddy
Kenny is Chinese he's Taiwanese he
walked around the cage
like I don't know why even though he's
already he's already Chinese
just and he posted a picture of him
doing this and it was like me like joke
or something like that did he knock out
a Chinese guy no he not he he fought
this this big black dude who was really
nice was DJ he's actually became friends
with them but but afterwards he just
just I don't know why it just the Heat
of the Moment you know you just cuz he's
a star dude he's a star exactly star he
he's the star he's a star got it but but
after the match he double flips the bird
and then my I didn't know that that
would happen what are you doing and then
the guy he beat well he lost to he ended
up winning the whole
tournament it just funny I could I
always thought that only happened if you
were like part of of a league and you
had a behavior it just it just you never
know like everyone's every tournament
this seems like a smaller tournament so
they may not have a better handling of
the rules and you you got to have a good
ref to be able to step in and be like
hey watch what the [__] you guys are
doing what would you do in that
situation where like the guy's clearly
just clumsy or [__] you know Spazzy
yeah like sometimes they're just so
unaware or sometimes they are malicious
right you just never know ref doesn't
have any under control but you still
have to deal with it what do you do do
you tell on them do you just keep
fighting what do you do yeah how you I
think I think and this guy kind of did
the right thing he crossed the line in
in um the guy who slapped him he was
kept Crossing Lines kept pushing
boundaries he was like [__]
it like whatever I'm going slap you so I
let you know what the f you can't be
doing this you know and sometimes that
does happen and you're it looks like he
was saying stuff as things were
happening he's like yo what the and you
know what's funny is the guy who gets
slapped looks at the ref like come on
you know so it's like but you see that
just double car Malone see that stuff
all the time isn't it isn't it cuz what
if they're having that reaction it's cuz
they really are clumsy and they're so
stupid that they don't know that they're
doing it it could be they're so stubborn
it could be that or in this the
ball-headed guy's mind it's like this is
[__] War I I'll do whatever it takes
and then you get [__] up that could be
it too but I feel like if you're an
intelligent fighter and you're fighting
like you know you pretty much know what
you're doing and that's the that's the
the side of it too is like people want
to act like U well I don't think they
want to act like but I think people play
Dum they play dumb or they're completely
In the Heat of the Moment where their
anxiety is through the roof and they
can't control it they can't control
their emotions they do [__] like that
right so like to me I don't watch a lot
of fights but when I watch this one it
looks very different like as a whole
definitely am I correct it looks way
more sporadic it doesn't look like a
normal Jiu-Jitsu fight it looks like two
guys fighting at a restaurant it looks
like guys that I don't I don't know know
what the level is this might be a black
belt match I don't know but that might
have something to do with it too the
level of the actual belts of the guys
who were competing M they might be brand
new begin they I don't they look like
they were trying to play a game like the
guy on bottom looked like he was trying
to get to positions where he would win
and the other guy on top looked like he
was just trying to be a little dirty
trying to get in his head you know look
at their reaction at the end and tell me
what what they're
saying hey
yeah he had a bruise on his shin like
you see that guy I on the guy in the
white meter seemed like he was trying to
do Jiu-Jitsu guy ballhead guy I don't
know I think he was just trying to be a
bully
me what yeah so he wins by
disqualification wow but it so is it
correct to assume that b guy throughout
the match he was kind of pushing it a l
he was instigating yeah I think he was
instigating I don't think he was being
kind of fell for his game in a way
[Music]
right